till cash writing in high what do you
think is the first step towards
marketing any product or person it's a
good question um so I think for a lot of
people you know it's easy to think of
the end goal you know we want to get
this many people to buy our products you
know we just want to get our name and
message out there but I think it's
important to kind of take a step back
and really consider how your product or
service it's going to help other people
out there so one example that I love is
Apple when they first came out with the
ipod their campaign was all about the
concept that you can have a thousand
songs in your pocket so you don't have
to worry about you know going through
all your CD collection you have all your
music with you everywhere you go and
they really understood that when they
were marketing to their audience and you
know they really captured on that
specific need of people who would want
to use their product and even those who
might not listen to a lot of music
because they maybe had trouble
unwrapping the little plastic on those
cd-rom cases and you know they just made
it so easy for people to get music and
have it with them everywhere they go so
their ability to really understand what
on what needs they were satisfying with
their product was so key and it helped
them you know really communicate with
with the world about you know the ipod
so cool yeah you know I'm a big believer
in core selling and core marketing and
that's so the first step in that is
figuring out what it is that you staying
for what are you staying for is a human
being what's the positive like you're
trying to have in the world and then use
that as your marketing where a lot of
people most people start off selling the
features you know our software can do
this and then somewhere along the way
they figure out to do benefit selling
benefits marketing well instead of just
being able to send out a thousand emails
are soft will help you build a better
relationship with your customers right
so you start getting two more the
benefits but the the bigger layer on top
of that the next graduation step is to a
course on what are you staying for why
is it important people want to know why
you're doing this business and why you
care
before they're going to pay attention to
you and so you know mine is all about
believe right here on the wall
everything I do flows through believe
making these webinars for you guys
making the videos that I do created a
products that I do and so I would start
if I was at the beginning kind of figure
out how to market my product I would
suffer thinking and what do I stand for
as a person as a company and then how
can I create a unique message that
resonates with me that I think will
resonate with my audience as well